well it's bringing in kaylee mcinnit uh
white house press secretary she's on the
other side of the building on the
northwest kaylee good morning to you
good to join you steve okay so when the
president signed that executive
order does he really intend to
implement those things or is this just
another one of those negotiation tactics
that donald trump is famous for
oh he most certainly intends to
implement the four executive orders
pertaining to unemployment insurance
student loans the payroll tax holiday
and evictions
the american people need relief and you
know chuck schumer it's funny listening
to him there
talk about these executive orders as not
being enough well what have democrats
put forward precisely nothing
except rejecting at least on two
occasions a 600
clean extension of unemployment
insurance they have been fundamentally
unserious and playing games on the back
of the american people
while president trump has acted in the
american people's best interest
kaylee there's violence uh and looting
in chicago we're seeing that actually on
the magnificent mile now the riots
in portland what's the president going
to do about that today
yeah so the president has put in place
operation legend
which has so far succeeded in arresting
250 individuals
and charging 250 individuals across the
country pertaining to civil unrest
um portland as you know we've secured
the courthouse but what has been so
interesting to see there
is finally it took 70 nights but finally
you have the liberal portland
mayor wheeler saying that if you lock
police officers in a building and tend
to trap them in there use an accelerant
to commit
arson you are committing attempted
murder not demonstrating
it is completely reckless that it took a
full 70 days
for the liberal mayor to finally
acknowledge that that's an unacceptable
status quo and these aren't just
peaceful demonstrations
as he tried to show wrongheadedly when
he walked among
these rioters so uh kaylee one of the
big stories uh
around the world remains coveted 19 and
the surge back in melbourne they shut
that city down it's coming back in
germany and spain
it's coming back in a little bit in
south korea and japan
but not like it is here and it goes back
to testing
now when you see the cdc evidently
is coming up with a saliva test what can
you tell us about
that and do you agree with some who say
if these labs can't get a test back to
an american citizen in less than three
days they shouldn't get paid for it
because they're useless
yeah i'll leave it to the president
about that specific provision but what i
would say is this dr burks and our team
here have been hard at work
to do pool testing to reduce the testing
turnaround time and we have seen some
success there
we in the united states have been number
one in testing in the entire world by a
long shot more than 65
million tests comparing that number two
at india to around 18 million
we've done extraordinary work and when
you talk about new tests brian like a
saliva test we have more than 100
emergency use authorizations exploring
even more testing capability above the
abba test and the rapid turnaround tests
and the other tests that are currently
available
on the commercial market you know
kayleigh something i've been
i was reading yesterday trying to catch
up after a week away
i'm shocked at the number of people who
are getting into fights
over masks i mean there was some guy who
punched i think a 75 year old guy
a partially disabled vet in the
in the jaw and broke his jaw because the
guy said hey you know
your girlfriend isn't wearing a mask
where does the president stand on
encouraging people don't get into a
fight about it
either they're going to wear a mask or
they're not yeah no one should be
fighting over this but what we should be
doing is doing what is patriotic which
is when you can't socially distance
wear a mask i was with the president
last week when he wore a mask when he
couldn't socially distance he's done it
several times
that's where he stands that it's the
american people it's the right thing to
do if you're
you know standing close to someone and
no one should be fighting over it
nevertheless
hey kaley what's the deal on the rapid
test because um
i know some friends that stood in line
for a long time they had to travel from
way out on long island down
over to brooklyn to get in line and get
these tests i know some other people
that have had they're only like three
clinics on long island that are doing
this
people who find out maybe someone they
are around has tested positive they want
to get the rapid test to know if they
need to go back to work or if they need
to quarantine
what's the latest on on getting more
rapid tests out there so people don't
have to wait in these long lines
yeah so it's important the rapid tests
are available throughout the nation but
we have prioritized making sure that the
rapid test gets to places where we have
vulnerable communities like our nursing
homes
where we've pushed a lot of this testing
to protect america's seniors
but there is even in our testing system
as it currently stands excess testing
capacity
because some of the tests that do take a
few days are not fully being utilized so
there's excess capacity in the system
but you're right that
surging rapid tests where we can is
important specifically in our nursing
homes
so china has sanctioned uh in response
to our sanctioning some of their
lawmakers they've sanctioned 11 of ours
including marco rubio ted cruz tom
cotton pat toomey
uh we have and also
another congressman from south jersey no
trump officials what's your reaction to
china's reaction to our sanctioning of
them
yeah china stands on notice because this
president has been
unmistakable uh in standing up to china
you've seen him with the phase two china
deal pushing that deal through like no
other president could or has in history
he's taken action sanctioning against
the abusive treatment of the uyghurs
no longer recognizing hong kong's
autonomous status because of chinese
intervention so this president has stood
unmistakable
china may try to sanction back as you
just noted
but this president has stood firm
against china and he'll continue to
all right kaylee thank you very much for
joining us today north london thank you
guys
thanks